hey so like what What's your deal I  believe we should destroy the old  systems of Oppression that sounds pretty  cool actually also there are quite a few  people I want to murder isn't that a  little counter-intuitive uh maybe  there's also a sad psychological reason  why I'm like this okay it was Christmas  1970. oh we're doing this now okay I  just been gifted a sled by my alcoholic  father hey so like what is your deal I'm  angry wow okay Santa luck boys we got  some innocence to care for any deeper  thing there I like the Army and I hate  the ocean I have any like backstory I  have a mustache and I'm pissed okay I am  literally evil ain't that right boys  okay hi everyone I hope you enjoyed the  video what type of characterization for  villains do you prefer click option one  or option two  [Music]  foreign